This is Sally.
She's a photographer.
Her bedroom is a mess, and she is usually at every party.
This is Jim.
He color coordinates his file folders,...
...spends a lot of time alone,...
...and is studying to be a lawyer.
Sally and Jim don't get along because they don't understand each other.
Well, there happens to be a really effective tool that explains why people are the way they are.
It's called Myers-Briggs type indicator.
It has four preferences on the sliding scale that make up a unique personality type that will explain a lot about who you are.
So, what do these all mean?
Well, an introvert's favorite world is their inner world,...
...while an extrovert's favorite world is the outer world.
A sensate takes in information in its basic form,...
...while an intuitive likes to interpret and add meaning to information.
A thinker makes decisions by being logical and consistent,...
...while a feeler makes decisions based on relationships and circumstances.
A person who is in the judgment category likes to have things decided,...
...while a perceiver likes to keep things open-ended.
There are a total of 16 different personality types which all have a unique way of living in this world.
Once you know your Myers-Briggs and you understand others' Myers-Briggs,...
...it's easy to understand yourself and to understand others.
Learn your Myers-Briggs here.